715 männer und 54 frauen sind am
hauptplatz in enns zur ausmusterung
angetreten
sie haben die ausbildung in der heeres
unter offiziers akademie kurz burg
genannt nun hinter sich gebracht und
haben ab sofort einen neuen dienstgrad
wachtmeister einer der sich an seine
ausbildung an der burg noch gut erinnern
kann ist heute verteidigungsminister
mario kunasek er weiß genau was die
insgesamt 769 soldatinnen und soldaten
heute noch so alles vorhaben also was
ich vorgehabt habe wo er womöglich
schnell nach hause zu kommen
das war eine lange lange zeit die man
weg ist immer nur am sonntag zu hause zu
sein und am sonntagabend schon wieder
zupacken und hierher zu fahren
aber die erwartungshaltung ist natürlich
eine große mann hat da sehr viel gelernt
man will ich das dann auch umsetzen in
der praxis und das sind jetzt dann auch
die anderen kommandanten gefordert die
älteren kameraden diese jungen und
offiziere hier in das system zu
implementieren sie begleiten zu betreuen
das lernen endet nicht mit dem heute
gesagt wer diese ausbildung einmal
durchgemacht hat wird das so schnell
auch nicht vergessen das ist schon ein
besonderer emotionaler moment natürlich
auch man denkt zurück und das jetzt hier
auf der akademie er war zwei mal hier
und als 97 und 2005 was ich kenne nicht
nur die akademie ich kenne auch die
stadt ganz gut
das ergibt sich automatisch wenn wir die
ganze woche hier ist aber ich glaube wir
haben eine optimale rahmenbedingungen
die heraus und sagte mir ist eine tolle
bildungseinrichtung und gemeinsam auch
mit den anderen schulen mit der neuen
komponenten bilden hier eine tolle
gruppe an menschen aus nämlich
unterversichert die jetzt mit dem
heutigen tag auch verantwortung
übernehmen als kommandanten auf der
gruppe neben aber die noch sehr viel vor
sich haben wenn es um ausbildung geht
und die wird ja weiterhin auch dieser
menschen und bei der weiterbildung
betreuen die weiterbildung hört eben nie
auf und das gilt auch für den
jahrgangsbesten der neun von zehn
möglichen auszeichnungen erreicht hat
doch das scheint für ihn nichts
außergewöhnliches zu sein
ich glaube es ist eine große ehre für
mich heute hier als lehrgangsbester
stehen zu dürfen ich bin ganz normale
bin mittendrin ich bin nicht besser
wieder sondern ist ein als kameraden und
kameradinnen wenngleich wie jeder andere
soldat und irgendwann wohnen heute gibt
es erstmals einen grund zum feiern und
wir freuen uns den israel
aus wachmeister uns eine aufgabe nach
dem zuhört und dafür gibt es vom
verteidigungsminister persönlich nur die
besten glückwünsche
ich wünsche ihnen dass sie die gleiche
schöne zeit erleben wie ich ich war 13
jahre aktiv beim bundeshaus unter tel
es ist für mich der schönste beruf den
man sich aussuchen kann ich wünsche
ihnen dass sie auch reifen in ihrer als
menschen greifen vorlegen die soziale
komponente nie vergessen und immer auch
wissen dass sie untergebene haben für
diese vorbilder seien
[Musik]